you had one of the best business
conferences I've ever went to you
managed to get speakers like Alex heroi
Gary ve Patrick B David and others how
were you able to pull that off my friend
Daryl EES and Mr Beast run vid Summit
and that's leans a little more
entertainment based we kind of lean more
business entrepreneur channels and
teachers so we're like who is a
celebrity guest speaker at the highest
of levels for entrepreneurs and Gary ve
is like in a way the One locking him in
155 I think his keynote fee went up
immediately double 155,000 yeah my man
and then I was like well what if we get
Patrick B David as well and then a
friend of mine knew Alex her Moi and
then I was like what if we also got we
eventually ended up spending
$917,000 on that event holy and we were
profitable in ticket sales what I
learned was scared money don't make
money right absolutely not